ah extra special guests surprise so
there's some things that you really have
to consider when you're shooting like
this and you want me to blow your minds
even further hey welcome back to another
episode of VFX artists react today we
are going to watch some really cool
clips and we got an extra special guest
surprise don't click that X button this
is from solo a Star Wars story and
there's something really interesting
about this sequence one is like it's a
pretty sweet train heist sequence and
all that but it ends in a very climactic
way here let's just watch it
[Applause]
whoa that's pretty cool oh that's neat
what's actually cool about this shot is
that everything is fake except for the
explosion wait this real it was actually
inspired by our good friend Gavin from
the slow mo guys so what they did was
they actually took a phantom camera they
3d printed the mountain and put it in a
giant fish tank and they shot it
something like 45 different times and
from different angles so what you're
seeing are real air bubbles within water
wrapping around the edges of the
mountain so it's like the perfect
simulation of a shot because it is
flawless simulation it's reality love
that they used real elements that is
salty waterfall level cool right
speaking of using real elements there's
a robot in this movie that was basically
a real robot told on set it's the same
thing they did on Game of Thrones but
they would have like this crazy-looking
skeleton dude with like a green screen
leg and they would just remove the leg
here's the thing about all of this
though they go through all the trouble
erasing out all of the internals and
they're like we're gonna keep all of the
actual costume bits in and then we
remove the green screen then we fill in
all the internal bits and then we
replace the entire costume sometimes
full CG is actually easier than
combining real and CG together if you
can just render it all in CG and have it
work together the lighting and the
shadows it might just be faster plus it
probably ends up looking better with the
actual like matte paintings of the
environment and all that stuff you can
see the biggest changes are the actual
reflections of the sky on the machine
itself she could have just been wearing
a mocap suit rather than the actual
robotic suit but it does put her 1 and a
better mindset for acting like a robot
and to the best lighting reference you
can possibly have so this is just a very
high budget version of bird up the worst
show on television
you got some poppy seeds in your mouth
this is an example of a lot of great
reference sunset but ultimately it gets
replaced with a CG model and so another
robot that also looked great was done
very practically there's a robot from my
m-mother I think you should take a look
oh right yet I still really want to see
that movie look really cool nope you
knew we were gonna talk about this how
are we not seen it yet it's supposed to
do my research
[Applause]
alright I'm gonna fire up my new
teleportation spell we're getting some
of you here who has seen I am mother hi
subscribe sorry to do this to you so
abruptly but recognize all of this
am I in a VFX artists react you are so
right now you are and for those of you
who don't know this is grants Victoria
the director of I am mother so just to
be clear though clan hasn't seen it so
have you seen it thought way too many
times yeah but I am very happy to
comment on anything that you need me to
talk about so the robot and I am mother
you guys put together a suit that is by
far one of the best practical robot
suits I've ever seen but you also have
some CG robot shots yeah it's almost the
secret of the film because we really
wanted to celebrate practical effects
when we were making this but when you're
making a low-budget film there are a
bunch of things that the script called
for that we couldn't let the suit do
wait how many suits did you have one you
only had one suit one suit end of movie
let's take a look at some shots from the
film and see if you can tell what CG and
what's real mother chilling
the babies in this film get born in 24
hours just an easy-bake oven for babies
so that that real baby was interacting
with that robot there so maybe the hands
are practical and you like that whole
frat house does
CG CG robot with baby can't get babies
to act that's tricky you can I can vouch
for that
oh now it's no longer a baby it's a
little girl oh yeah engine that looks
real to me because of how it's moving
like the slight jiggles the stuff it's
hard to get that right the little girls
obviously CG as well throughout that
whole sequence of shots it's all real
there's one shot that made me think like
okay that was pretty dang real it was
the close-up on the wrist you get the
really nice detail in the highlights and
scratches and stuff see what's
interesting is that shot is completely
real
but another shot that's equally tight
and closed it is actually CJ really yeah
credit to the VFX guys of Finn they
built the CG mother after we've made the
real mother so it's all about photo
scans and like light are scanning mother
okay why would you choose to have the
baby holding on to a CG hand rather than
a practical in this instance we've got a
better performance from the baby when
the baby was interacting with a real
mother there she is looking at a robot
that's completely real Oh like it was it
was changeable initially we had the baby
interacting with the robot with the head
off so like she understood that like the
really sweet man that was playing mother
Luke Walker was inside this bit of
costume and eventually we put the head
on but the shot where the baby gets put
on the floor and you see mother's feet
that's actually shichi I actually
thought that was real because the babies
interacting yet not that's CJ that shots
follows those things we're gonna sit
side by side in this sequence and
throughout the whole film the bar was
set really high it was basically realism
like it's got to look real and the VFX
guys got that so okay even sitting down
at the table there I actually thought
that was a real shot but that's a
computer-generated shot now yeah well
the original plan on shots like this
were that like let's have the real sued
and then just replace the hands like
let's have the hands go faster oh yeah
but it actually proved to be more
difficult to get those arms to feel like
they were locked to the body than it was
to just completely replace mother and
that was something that we felt
increasingly confident doing
that's the story that's wait why is he
in his underwear it was like this was
like the last day of second-unit
photography and so there was nothing for
Luke to wear and so he was just gonna do
it in the clothes that he was wearing
but the VFX guys were like it's all
black like in a dark environment we
can't see you and then Luke being the
exhibitionist that he is is like what
about skin like would you be able to
track and follow this thing give great
lighting reference as well on any other
visual effects artists react episode I
would ask you how did you make the CG
suits look surreal but at this time I'm
gonna flip it how did you make the real
suit look so CG it's ultimately about
hiding the fact that there's a person in
there right you want the audience to
suspend disbelief and there's a bunch of
tricks that we're doing to be able to do
that mother's head is actually sitting a
couple of inches above Luke's head and
that allows you to create these sort of
cavities like in around our neck line
that make it look like there's nowhere
to hide a person that would that took
like six months like to get worked out
like what exactly mother looked like I
knew I always wanted it to look like a
real robot the robot kinda reminds me of
like the eventual evolution of the boss
totally I want to see Clint in a mocap
CG mother fighting mother like that'll
be great as a director on this project
how much of a difference do you think it
would make having a practical versus a
CG suit what exactly are you seeing in
the performance that changes pot of it
is like everybody actually being on the
same page and sharing the same reality
and that's like within the confines of
the scenes
you described to us what we're seeing
with this weird like I wanna see all
about this this blue screen suit that
you've developed yeah it kind of looks
like wow this is a really high-end film
with a fancy blue version of mother that
they're using for CG but this is
actually a black foam suit that whether
built before they built the real sued as
a test case but you still have the suit
sitting around exactly and we just got a
couple of cans of blue spray paint and
we just spray painted it blue that's it
it's so important because when you've
got that interaction from an actor like
with what's ultimately going to become a
CG thing you need the terrain to sort of
map at one point I know you guys were
shooting at a beach but it's all this
like foggy tree sort of stuff and I
couldn't really see too much of the
original beach in the shot all of the
outside world is filmed on the same
Beach like so when clara reaches the
beach that's the same place where the
bunker door is right but we used CG to
kind of create the variety and the
landscapes to make it feel like you've
covered a greater terrain i think this
movie's really showcasing a pretty big
turning point of visual effects where
you guys had a budget but it's not a
huge budget they had i know exactly what
you mean like you know netflix bought
the film at Sundance it was made
completely independently it was made in
Australia and we'd never had enough
money but we working with VFX companies
that were really skilled really
passionate and really wanting to prove
themselves well grant is amazing having
you here amazing being here and if you
want to kind of get in touch with you
what's what's the best way to do that
Instagram at Grant's Batory great and do
you want me to teleport you back to
Australia
that would be super convenient it is a
long flight all right here we go
all right Clint get back over here I got
a great Instagram shot of that
think of Instagram you can follow us at
corridor digital go check it out through
to our patreon month oh yeah do patreon
all right so do you support us on
patreon you can vote on what one of the
videos will be that we react to this
winner came out of left field Space Jam
let's see if I remember how to do this
man Michael Jackson Michael Jordan this
is at the beginning of motion tracking
like camera tracking like the movies
before that we're still doing it
manually and they ended up kind of
developing their own software to do all
of the camera tracking they filmed all
of Michael Jackson Jordan yeah they shot
any of their people on a green-screen
stage with red tracking markers and then
they recreated the entire court
digitally this is the first time I
remember seeing Looney Tunes with like
proper shading as opposed to the classic
2d shading the hand-drawn 2d drawings of
each of the Looney Tunes characters
there's just one pass flat lighting
right and they do a whole pass of like
any shading and they would be able to
adjust that and blur it out where
necessary if they needed to adjust the
amount of directional lighting on them
it was pretty sweet oh how do you think
a cartoon character passes a basketball
to a real-life person like Michael
Jackson dang it Michael Jordan is maybe
using him for 10 basketball I think it's
one of the first photo scans oh really
they took hundreds of photos of this
basketball from every possible angle and
recreated it in 3d anytime the cartoon
characters are dribbling around they're
dribbling a 3d rendered ball and they
made it look as close to the real ball
that Michael Jackson was using on set if
you guys have a movie or a show with
some sweet visual effects please leave a
comment down below we read them all we
actually have a really fun time going
through all the comments so please keep
it up let's take it from 1998 to the
Year 2019 here
let's talk about Gemini man to me there
being you man alright so we just had a
chance to see Gemini man in theaters all
of us in 3d at 120 frames per second but
let's just say that I actually really
enjoyed the action in this movie and it
was pretty cool that was what they were
trying to do with the Hobbit back in the
day I wasn't the biggest fan of that
kind of high frame rate on The Hobbit
this was different so there's some
things that you really have to consider
when you're shooting like this I think
angry dug down into it when you're
watching something that's 4k at 120
frames per second in 3d you can tell
when the actors are wearing makeup did
any of the actors wear make no I mean
this subtle makeup here and their
traditional makeup is not present in
this movie but here's the thing so fight
scenes right when you can see every
little bit of motion you can tell when a
sudden man is gonna throw their face
before the hand connects at a hundred
try your friends for Soho right don't
see that at 24 so these fight scenes
they need to actually go in and
reanimate them so it's only throws a
punch the face doesn't move until the
hand is pushing the face but you know
what we're digressing because what the
heck who is that
that's he dun Will Smith let's talk a
little bit about some of the technology
they had to do in Gemini man to get him
to look real you know I like talking
about how Poor's got a stretch oh yeah I
poor as stretch for Gemini man they
didn't just take a texture with pores
and like figure out how to stretch they
took the model and they had a procedural
generation of pores on the face you look
in the back your hand right and you go
like this you'll see very fine wrinkles
and that's the platelets of your skin is
stacking up on top of each other and so
the procedural pores and the procedural
platelets let them have the wrinkles
follow the appropriate cracks and
crevices to get exactly perfect micro
wrinkles for the skin didn't what a
digital do all the effects yes for this
what are the effects company yeah
anyways shush
so it wrinkles is important to get right
but skin tone is important to get right
to so once again in CG graphics you
might just throw texture on there right
not in this movie they had melanin
simulation if you go like this the blood
gets pushed out of the parts of your
skin that gets squished or pushed back
into it
this is the kind of stuff you have to
think about when you do the human face
it is not easy and you want me to blow
your minds even further the shots with
jhemini man
they are motion capturing his entire
body and they rendered the entire body
as a digital replacement only problem I
had with this movie was the motion of a
lot of different things same the
dirtbike it hurt a pause on any of this
it looks flawless but the motion is what
doesn't work for me like that tail whip
on the bike was like really quick so
when things break the rules of gravity
like in this case the dirt bikes very
subtle but we can all tell that it
doesn't feel right it just goes to show
that I think motion is pretty much the
hardest thing to get right he has to die
is your darkness you had to walk through
this on your own do your animators stop
moving the upper lip please because
there is no muscle going from your nose
down to your lip to pull it straight up
that's Garry's Mod that's not reality
this one his bottom lip is pushing his
top lip up it looks correct that looks
yeah there's another scene that he's
just sitting there is listening and he's
and moding and his upper lip tickles mmm
he like slides up and down as he's kind
of like sneering it's kind of a
byproduct of morph targets and motion
tracking but it's not just Gemini man
anytime there's a CG face if it looks
fake take a look at the upper lip and
watch it slide up on its own because
there's no muscle there and
subconsciously you know it and anytime a
CG face does it you really can tell it's
fake isn't that what we saw the deep
fake do better with Princess Leia it is
always saw the deep fake do better it's
been so couldn't you just do a deep fake
on Will Smith and maybe fix the lip you
know I'm glad you asked friend we want
to do a deep fake of Will Smith and see
how it compares to Gemini man it took us
a while we actually found a really
really really good Will Smith
impersonator super nice guy take a look
at this I think it's one of the best
Will Smith deep fakes you've ever seen
you may have seen our Tom Cruise he
fakes our Keanu Reeves deep fakes and we
have been perfecting the technology and
we think we have people
it's a lot of work but we're finally
here no you don't make sure that the
person underneath the deep fake like has
the same statue at the same mannerisms
right it's all about the performance and
the personality so uh we'll what's your
favorite hot sauce red red bird so
realistic it's so convincing it's all in
the performance check out how high
resolution is and looks like the
expressions are perfectly captured he
shows like a big expression move that's
great so I just want to point out the
key to this technology is having the
perfect person underneath to capture
that performance so I just want to say
big things here to our Will Smith for
helping us out gotcha thanks still Smith
appreciate you being our video super
nice guy
anyways I didn't mean if you do like
action and you want to see action the
way you haven't seen it before try to
catch the high frame rate screening of
it I do I do highly recommend it
absolutely is as a movie
I have critiques but as an experience
you got to go see it and you know I
would really really really like it here
to subscribe if you're not subscribed
already so this is called a hanpan
it's basically a distant relative of a
steel drum
[Music]
what those of you don't know we actually
have a patreon account which helps
support this show and you can even vote
on whatever movies you want in every
episode that's where a Space Jam came
from today but we also have some very
special patrons that we want to thank
specifically today starting with Bailey
Wilson Dave crooks Harris Reds hajeck
Oscar bunting Philip Oxford Ellen
Almanza war master 236 not a Canadians
by Mitch Glenn ski skanky snack glitz
cube James Bailey Brian and toesik and
many more big lists here kind of like at
the end of a big movie was going the
other scrolling dude that's a lot wait
for that post credit scene thanks please
support us on patreon you helped make
this show possible and thank you